the real job of a leader is not about
being in charge it's about taking care
of those in our charge when we're Junior
our only responsibility is to be good at
our jobs that's all we really have to do
and if you're good at your job they'll
promote you
and at some point
you'll get promoted to a position where
we're now responsible for the people who
do the job we used to do but nobody
shows us how to do that we have to go
through this transition of being
responsible for the job and then turning
into somebody who's now responsible for
the people who are responsible for the
job we all have the capacity to be a
leader doesn't mean everybody should be
a leader and it doesn't mean everybody
wants to be a leader and the reason is
because it comes at Great personal
sacrifice
remember you're not in charge you're
responsible for those in your charge